Je parle de la compassion d'un point de vue islamique,
et ma foi n'est peut-être pas très bien perçue
comme étant basée sur la compassion.
La vérité est l'inverse.
Notre livre sacrée, le Coran, comprend 114 chapitres,
et chaque chapitre débute avec ce que nous appellons le "bismillah",
c'est à dire au nom d'Allah, le compatissant, le très miséricordieux,
ou, comme Sir Richard Burton,
pas le Richard Burton qui a épousé Elizabeth Taylor,
Mais le Sir Richard Burton qui a vécu un siècle avant cela
et qui était un globe-trotter
et traducteur de nombreux ouvrages littéraires,
le traduit ainsi:"au nom de Dieu, qui compatit, le compatissant."
Et dans un extrait du Coran, qui pour les Musulmans est Dieu parlant à l'humanité,
Dieu dit au prophète Mahomet,
qui, tel que nous le croyons, est le dernier d'une série de prophètes,
débutant avec Adam, incluant Noé, incluant Moïse, incluant Abraham,
incluant Jésus-Christ, et se terminant avec Mahomet,
a dit: "Nous ne t'avons envoyé, ô Mahomet,
que comme un Rahman, comme source de compassion pour l'humanité."
Et pour nous êtres humains, et certainement pour nous Musulmans,
dont la mission et l'objectif, en suivant la voie du prophète,
est de devenir le plus possible semblable au prophète,
et le prophète, dans une de ses paroles, dit:
"Parez-vous des attributs de Dieu."
Et parce que Dieu lui-même a dit que son attribut premier est la compassion,
en fait, le Coran dit que :"Dieu prononça la compassion sur lui-même,"
ou "a regné par la compassion."
Ainsi notre objectif et notre mission doit être d'êtres des sources de compassion,
activateurs de compassion, acteurs de compassion,
et conteurs de compassion, et artisanat de compassion.
C'est beau tout ça,
mais où errons-nous,
et quelle est la source du manque de compassion dans le monde?
Pour la réponse à cette question, nous nous tournons vers notre spiritualité.
Dans chaque tradition religieuse, il y a ce que l'on appelle une voie extérieure et une voie intérieure
ou une voie exotérique et une voie ésotérique.
La voie ésotérique de l'Islam est plus communément connue sous le nom de Soufisme, ou tasawwuf en Arabe.
Et ses docteurs et ses savants,
ces maîtres spirituels de la tradition Soufie,
se réfèrent aux enseignements et aux exemples de notre prophète,
qui nous enseignent où se trouve la source de nos problèmes,
Au cours d'une batailles menée par le prophète,
il a dit à ces fidèles:"Nous retournons de la moindre guerre
vers la plus grande guerre, la plus grande bataille."
Et ils dirent:"Messager de Dieu, nous sommes fatigués.
Comment pouvons-nous aller vers une plus grande bataille?"
Il dit:"Celle-là est la bataille du soi, la bataille de l'égo."
Les sources des problèmes humains ont à voir avec l'égoïsme, le Je.
Le célèbre maître Rumi, qui est connu de la plupart d'entre vous,
a une histoire dans laquelle il parle d'un homme qui va chez un ami
et frappe à la porte,
et une voix répond:"Qui est là?"
"C'est moi" ou de manière plus grammaticalement correct,"C'est Je,"
comme cela se dit en anglais.
La voix dit:"Va-t'en."
Après plusieurs années d'entraînement, de discipline, de recherche et d'efforts,
il revient,
et avec beaucoup plus d'humilité, il cogne de nouveau à la porte.
La voix demande:"Qui est là?"
il répondit:"C'est toi, ô briseur de coeurs."
La porte s'ouvre, et la voix dit:
"Entre, il n'y a pas de place dans cette maison pour deux Je,
deux Moi, deux moi-même, deux égos.
Et les histoires de Rumi sont des métaphores de la voie spirituelle,
En présence de Dieu, il n'y a pas de place pour plus d'un Je,
et c'est le Je de la divinité.
Dans un enseignement, qu'on appelle dans notre tradition un hadith Qudsi,
Dieu dit:"Mon serviteur",ou "Ma créature, ma créature humaine,
ne s'approche de moi aisément d'aucune autre manière
qu'en faisant ce que leur ai demandé."
Et ceux de vous qui sont des employeurs savent exactement ce dont je parle.
Vous voulez que vos employés fassent ce que vous leur demandez,
et s'ils l'ont fait, alors ils peuvent faire des choses supplémentaires,
mais qu'ils n'ignorent pas ce que vous leur avez demandé de faire.
Et Dieu dit:"Mon serviteur continue de s'approcher de moi,
en continuant de faire ce que je lui ai demandé de faire,"
des crédits supplémentaires, on pourrait dire,
jusqu'à ce que je l'aime.
Et quand j'aime mon serviteur,"dit Dieu,
"Je deviens les yeux par lesquels il ou elle voit,
les oreilles par lesquelles il ou elle entend,
la main par laquelle il ou elle prend,
et le pied par lequel il ou elle marche,
et le coeur par lequel il ou elle comprend."
C'est cette union du soi avec la divinité
qui est la leçon et la raison de notre chemin spirituel et de toutes nos traditions de foi.
Les Musulmans voient en Jésus le maître du Soufisme,
le plus grand prophète et messager qui vint faire valoir le chemin spirituel.
Quand il dit:"Je suis l'esprit, je suis la voie,"
quand le prophète Mahomet dit:"Quiconque m'a vu a vu Dieu."
c'est parce qu'ils sont devenus de tels instruments de Dieu,
qu'ils font partie de la valeur de Dieu,
tels que la volonté de Dieu était manifeste à travers eux
et qu'ils n'agissaient pas par eux-mêmes et par leurs égos.
La compassion sur terre nous est donnée, elle est en nous.
Tout ce que nous avons à faire est de repousser nos égos,
mettre de côté notre égoïsme,
Je suis certain, probablement vous tous, ou certainement une grande majorité,
avez déjà eu ce que vous appelleriez une expérience spirituelle,
un moment dans vos vies où, pour quelques secondes, une minute peut-être,
les frontières de votre égo se sont dissoutes.
Et dans cette minute, vous vous sentiez unis à l'univers,
unis à cette carafe d'eau, unis avec chaque être humain,
unis avec le créateur,
et vous sentiez, en présence du pouvoir, de l'émotion,
de l'amour le plus complet, une compassion et une pitié des plus profondes
comme vous n'en aviez jamais ressenti avant.
Cela est le moment qui est un cadeau de Dieu à nous,
un cadeau qui, pour un moment, lève la barrière
qui nous fait insister sur le je je je, moi moi moi,
et plutôt, comme la personne dans l'histoire de Rumi,
nous disons: "Ô, c'est tout toi."
C'est tout toi. Et c'est tout nous.
Et nous, et je, et nous font tous partie de toi.
Tout créateur, tout l'objectif, la source de notre être,
et la fin de notre voyage.
Tu es aussi le briseur de nos coeurs
Tu es celui vers lequel nous devrions tous être, notre raison de vivre,
et pour lequel nous mourrons,
et pour lequel nous serons ressuscités
pour rendre compte à Dieu à quel point nous avons été des êtres de compassion.
Notre message aujourd'hui, et notre but aujourd'hui,
et ceux de vous qui sont ici aujourd'hui,
et le but de cette charte de la compassion, est de rappeler.
Parce que le Coran nous presse toujours de se remémorer, et de rappeler aux autres,
parce que la connaissance de la vérité est dans chaque être humain.
Nous savons tout.
Nous avons accès à tout.
Jung l'appelait le subconscient.
À travers notre subconscient, dans vos rêves,
que le Coran appelle, notre état de sommeil, la moindre mort,
la mort temporaire.
Dans notre état de sommeil nous faisons des rêves, nous avons des visions,
Nous voyageons même hors de nos corps, pour plusieurs d'entre nous,
et nous voyons des choses merveilleuses.
Nous voyageons au delà des limites de l'espace tel que nous le connaisssons,
et au delà les limites du temps comme nous le connaissons.
Mais tout ceci est pour glorifier le nom du créateur
dont le nom premier est le compatissant, le miséricordieux.
Dieu, Bokh, peu importe le nom que vous lui donnez, Allah, Ram, Om,
peu importe le nom avec lequel vous nommez
ou accédez à la présence de la divinité,
est le locus de l'être absolu,
l'amour et la pitié et la compassion absolus,
et la connaissance et la sagesse absolues,
ce que les Hindous appellent satchidananda.
La langue diffère,
mais l'objectif est le même.
Rumi a une autre histoire
dans laquelle trois personnes, un Turc, un Arabe,
et j'oublie la troisième, mais disons, ça pourrait être un Malais.
Le premier demande de l'angour, disons qu'un d'eux est un Français,
le deuxième demande de l'eneb, et le dernier demande du raisin.
Et ils se disputent et se battent,
je veux du raisin, je veux de l'eneb, je veux de l'angour,
ne sachant pas que le mot qu'ils utilisent
réfère à la même réalité dans différentes langues.
Il n'y a par définition qu'une réalité absolue,
parce que, par définition, l'absolu est singulier,
et absolu et unique.
Il y a cette absolue concentration de l'être,
cette absolue concentration de la conscience,
de la perception, un locus absolu de compassion et d'amour
qui définit les attributs premiers de la divinité.
Et ceux-ci devraient aussi être
les attributs premiers qui définissent ce que c'est que d'être humain.
Ce qui définit l'humanité, biologiquement peut-être,
c'est notre physiologie,
mais Dieu définit l'humanité par notre spiritualité, par notre nature.
Et le Coran dit, il parle aux anges et dit:
"Quand j'aurai terminé la création d'Adam à partir de la glaise,
et que j'aurai insufflé mon esprit en lui,
alors prosternez-vous devant lui."
Les anges se prosternent, non devant le corps humain,
mais devant l'âme humaine.
Pourquoi? Parce que l'âme, l'âme humaine,
est imprégnée d'une partie du souffle divin,
une partie de l'âme divine.
Ceci est aussi dit dans le vocabulaire biblique
lorsqu'on nous enseigne que nous avons été créé à l'image divine.
Quelle est l'image de Dieu?
L'image de Dieu, c'est l'être absolu,
la conscience, la connaissance et la sagesse absolues,
et l'amour et la compassion absolus.
Ainsi, le fait que nous soyons humains,
dans le plus grand sens de ce qu'est être un humain,
dans le sens le plus heureux de ce qu'est être un humain,
signifie que nous devons aussi être les régisseurs adéquats
du souffle divin qui est en nous,
et que nous devons chercher à parfaire en nous les attributs de l'être,
d'être vivant, d'être soi,
l'attribut de la sagesse, de la conscience,
et l'attribut d'être des individus aimants et compatissants.
Ceci est ce que je comprends de ma tradition de foi,
et c'est ce que je comprends de mes études des autres traditions de foi,
et c'est la plateforme commune sur laquelle nous devons nous tenir,
et lorsque nous nous dressons ainsi sur cette plateforme
je suis convaincu que nous pouvons faire un monde merveilleux.
Et je crois, personnellement, que nous sommes tout près,
et qu'avec la présence et l'aide de gens comme vous ici,
nous pouvons accomplir la prophétie d'Isaïe.
Il prédit qu'arriverait un temps
où les gens transformeront leurs épées en socs,
et n'apprendront plus la guerre et ne la feront plus.
Nous avons atteint une étape dans l'histoire humaine, où nous n'avons plus le choix.
Nous devons, nous devons diminuer nos égos,
contrôler nos égos, que ce soit l'égo individuel, l'égo personnel,
l'égo familial, l'égo national,
et nous devons tout laisser être pour la gloire du Un.
Merci, et que Dieu vous bénisse.
(Applaudissements)